>>> THE HOUSE SECT COMMITTEE
IS PREPARING FOR ITS NEXT ROUND
OF HEARINGS AND A REPORT ON ITS
FINDINGS.
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR, MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN PIECING TOGETHER
TESTIMONY FROM OVER A THOUSAND
WITNESSES, ALONG WITH VIDEOS,
TEXTS, E-MAILS, AND OTHER
DOCUMENTS.
THE COMMITTEE'S CHAIRMAN SAYS
THE GOAL IS TO RESTART HEARINGS
ON SEPTEMBER 28th.
JOINING ME NOW IS COMMITTEE
MEMBER, JAMIE RASKIN, DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN FROM MARYLAND.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON,
CONGRESSMAN.
SO LET'S LOOK AHEAD NOW TO THAT
NEXT HEARING AT THE END OF THIS
MONTH.
CAN YOU GIVE US ANYMORE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT WE CAN
EXPECT TO LEARN?
NEW TESTIMONY, NEW WITNESSES,
ANY STUNNING NEW INFORMATION?
GIVE US A GLIMPSE.
>> WELL, THE MEETING IS AT LEAST
PROVISIONALLY SCHEDULED FOR
SEPTEMBER 28th AND WE'RE HOPING
WE'LL BE ABLE TO DO THE HEARING
ON THE 28th OF SEPTEMBER.
AND, YOU KNOW, THIS IS A HEARING
WHERE I HOPE THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO COMPLETE THE STORY SO
THAT AMERICA HAS A COMPREHENSIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S EFFORTS TO OVERTHROW
THE 2020 ELECTION AND WE'RE ABLE
TO PUT THAT IN ITS COMPLETE,
HISTORICAL, AND POLITICAL
CONTEXT AND WE'RE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND THE COORDINATION OF
THE INSIDE POLITICAL COUP WITH
THE OUTDOOR VIOLENT INSURRECTION
THAT CAME INDOORS AND OVERRAN
BOTH THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE,
DRIVING US OUT OF OUR CHAMBERS
AND DROVE THE VICE PRESIDENT OUT
OF THE CAPITOL.
SO, WE'RE HOPING TO PULL THE
WHOLE THING TOGETHER AND WE HAVE
NEW INFORMATION ABOUT DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF OUR INVESTIGATION.
>> WHAT ASPECTS?
>> WELL, I THINK WE'RE FILLING
IN A LOT OF GAPS, THINGS THAT
WERE, YOU KNOW, LEFT BEFORE
STILL OPEN.
AND SOME NEW THINGS HAVE OPENED
UP, OF COURSE.
YOU KNOW, THERE IS A MYSTERY OF
THESE MANY MISSING TEXTS FROM
THE SECRET SERVICE.
WE WANT TO KNOW HOW THOSE TEXTS
CAME TO BE MISSING.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, WE WANT TO
TRY TO GET THE INFORMATION THAT
WAS IN THOSE TEXTS AND SEE WHAT
WE CAN FIND AND SEE HOW
REVEALING THEY ARE IN A
CORROBORATING WAY, OF THE BASIC
ELEMENTS OF THE STORY THAT WE
SET FORTH BEFORE.
>> SO, HAVE YOU LEARNED ANYTHING
MORE FROM THOSE TEXTS, IN TERMS
OF WHAT HAS BEEN RECOVERED, NOT
RECOVERED?
>> IN GENERAL, LET ME JUST SAY
THIS, WITHOUT GOING INTO
SPECIFIC PIECE OF EVIDENCE.
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT MORE SINCE
WE, YOU KNOW, TOOK OUR BREAK
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO.
WE'RE ABLE TO FILL IN A LOT MORE
ABOUT THE INTENTIONALITY WITH
WHICH THE EVENTS TOOK PLACE.
WE'RE ABLE TO FILL IN AL MORE
ABOUT THE MOVEMENT OF DIFFERENT
ACTORS, AND WE'RE ABLE TO FILL
IN MORE ABOUT WHAT ACTUALLY WENT
DOWN ON JANUARY 6th ITSELF.
SO, I THINK PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TAKEN AN INTEREST IN THIS
UNPRECEDENTED AND OBVIOUSLY
HISTORIC EVENT OF AN ASSAULT ON
AN AMERICAN PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION AND AN ATTEMPT BY A
SITTING PRESIDENT WHO LOST AN
ELECTION TO SEIZE THE
PRESIDENCY, I THINK WILL FIND
THE REMAINING DETAILS THAT HAVE
BEEN UNEARTHED VERY INSTRUCTIVE,
TO COMPLETE THE PICTURE.
I'M ALSO VERY INTERESTED IN
AMERICA UNDERSTANDING TO WHAT
EXTENT THE VARIOUS KIND OF
THREATS WE SAW UNFOLD ON JANUARY
6th STILL OUT THERE.
I THINK WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND TO
WHAT EXTENT AMERICAN DEMOCRACY
IS STILL UNDER ATTACK, AND TO
WHAT EXTENT OUR ELECTIONS ARE
STILL VULNERABLE TO
INSURRECTION, COUP, POLITICAL
VIOLENCE, AND SABOTAGE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO, WHAT I HEAR FROM YOU IS THAT
THIS WILL ROUND OUT THE PICTURE
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
PUTTING FORWARD FOR MANY MONTHS
NOW.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS, THERE IS
STILL KEY TESTIMONY AND
DOCUMENTS THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
NOT RECEIVED.
I KNOW YOU'RE STILL TALKING TO
NEWT GINGRICH, AS WELL AS JENNY
THOMAS, THE WIFE OF JUSTICE
THOMAS.
AT WHAT POINT DOES THAT END AND
THE COMMITTEE MOVES INTO JUST
GETTING ITS FINAL REPORT OUT?
>> AS YOU'VE MENTIONED, WE'VE
TALKED TO MORE THAN A THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
WE'VE LOOKED AT TENS OF
THOUSANDS, PERHAPS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF DOCUMENTS
AT THIS POINT.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THERE'S
EVER BEEN A CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION OF THIS
BREATHTAKING SCOPE AND
COMPREHENSIVENESS.
AND YET, STILL, IT IS OOH VERY
STRONG FIRST DRAFT OF HISTORY
AND UNDOUBTEDLY THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN CONCEALING THINGS
AND PEOPLE NOT COMING FORWARD.
AND, WE KNOW WE HAVE TO GO WITH
ALL OF THE EVIDENCE WE'VE GOT.
BUT WE FEEL VERY CONFIDENT THAT
WE UNDERSTAND ALL OF THE BASIC
ELEMENTS OF THE MULTIPLE
OFFENSES AGAINST AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY THAT TOOK PLACE OVER
THE COURSE OF THESE EVENTS.
>> OKAY, BUT BOTTOM LINE IS, AS
IT STANDS NOW, DO YOU EXPECT TO
SPEAK WITH NEWT GINGRICH OR
GINNY THOMAS.
AND I SHOULD ALSO PUT IN THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT, MIKE
PENCE, AS WELL.
JUST HELP US GET SOME CLARITY ON
THAT.
>> WELL, NO, I APPRECIATE THE
INTEREST.
AS YOU KNOW, WHAT WE HAVE NOT
COMMENTED ON SPECIFIC WITNESSES
WHO ARE COMING IN.
WE DON'T WANT TO INTERFERE WITH
THAT PROCESS.
AND, YOU KNOW, ALL I CAN SAY IS
THAT WE ARE AND HAVE BEEN AND
REMAIN DEEPLY INTERESTED IN THE
TESTIMONY OF ANYONE WHO HAS
RELEVANT INFORMATION THAT IS
MATERIAL TO ALL OF THE PRINCIPLE
COMPONENTS OF THIS ASSAULT ON
AMERICAN CONSTITUTIONAL
DEMOCRACY.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, EVEN AT THIS
LATE DATE, I WOULD SAY, IF THERE
ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO HAVE
BEEN RESTING WHERE THEIR
CONSCIENCE OR WHO BELIEVE THEY
MAY BE SOMETHING THAT THEY
DIDN'T REALIZE BEFORE WAS
RELEVANT, THEN, YOUNG, BRING IT
IN.
WE CAN OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW,
SCREEN OUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
ENGAGED IN, YOU KNOW, FRIVOLOUS
SUBMISSIONS.
BUT, IF THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE HAD A CHANGE OF HEART, AND
CERTAINLY WE HAVE HAD PEOPLE
BWHO
HAVE HAD A CHANGE OF HEART.
IF THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
RECOGNIZING THE RELEVANCE OF
SOMETHING THEY HAVE NOT
UNDERSTOOD BEFORE, COME ON IN,
BRING IT IN.
WE ARE TRYING TO GET THE
COMPLETE AND TOTAL TRUTH OUT TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
TO THE PEOPLE'S DEMOCRACY AND
THE PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
WHO ARE --
>> I KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT WITNESSES COMING UP, BUT
NEWT GINGRICH, GINNY THOMAS,
MIKE PENCE, THE COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN VERY OPEN, YOU KNOW,
RELEASING LETTERS TO THE PUBLIC,
SAYING THAT WE WANT TO HEAR FROM
YOU.
SO THAT'S WHY I THINK IT IS FAIR
TO ASK FOR AN UPDATE ON WHERE
THINGS STAND THERE.
>> I CAN'T TELL YOU, BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW THE UP TO THE MINUTE
UPDATE ON WHERE WE ARE.
I DON'T WANT TO INTERFERE IN
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS THAT ARE
ALWAYS DELICATE, BUT WE WANT
PEOPLE TO COME IN AND THEY
SHOULD UNDERSTAND, THEY HAVE A
LAWYER THERE, OBVIOUSLY, IF THEY
THINK THEY ARE INCRIMINATING
THEMSELVES IN SOME WAY, THEY CAN
ASSERT THE FIFTH AMENDMENT.
WE RESPECT THAT.
BUT IN GENERAL, EVERYBODY OWES
THE CONGRESS HIS OR HER TRUTHFUL
TESTIMONY ABOUT WHAT TOOK PLACE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN JAMIE RASKIN, THANKS
FOR YOUR TIME TONIGHT.
>> YOU BET.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.